welcome children to the crevice the cave
the stash of little videos on my second
channel
mugs available now
oh man drake that wrong questions from
you number one what's a book show or
game that you love even though you know
it's utter garbage quality wise and why
pirates of the caribbean at world's end
and the matrix revolutions which as far
as i know are generally regarded as like
not that good films they maybe not be
like utterly garbage but compared to
like their predecessors i think so
i just love them they're so much fun the
music in that world's end is just
brilliant it's amazing it's the best
soundtrack of the series and the matrix
revolutions like it's just just so cool
to watch i loved it as a kid and it
stuck with me number two when can we
expect your first fiction novel or
unwriting word building for youtube to
be published i am taking my first
fiction novel to agents and publishers
by the end of this year that is my goal
as for writing and word building if you
don't know it is a book that captures
all of the on writing word building
content that i make refines it edits it
puts it into a book that's a lot easier
to reference than finding stuff in a
video is it sold like 30 000 copies so
far pretty damn happy with that i am so
much happier with volume 2 than volume
1. i've put in so much more work there
is thousands and thousands of words of
new content in there with way better
examples way more commentary and it is
going to be out by the end of the year i
swear to you along with the audiobook
now i have to and if you want to get
volume 1 links down below question 3
cat cat all hail supreme leader momo
question four which books movies or
games had such an impression on you that
you personally needed to take time to
think over everything you just
experienced and you know what's weird i
get asked all the time what are the best
stories you've ever experienced and i
always go i don't know but by asking
this i actually turned up with 10
stories that have stayed with me forever
and if those aren't the best stories
that i've ever heard then
what else would they be number one the
film history boys by ellen bennett got
me thinking so much about the place of
education in our lives and society
number two house of leaves by marx
danielski which is just
i cannot even begin to explain what it's
like but it uh definitely leaves an
impression
you might say number three annihilation
by jeff vandemier it is this brilliant
deconstruction of what it means to be a
person and who you are and it's written
just stunningly number four near
automated goes without saying number
five paper towns by john green bit
unexpected but it's got some great
introspective writing and it's a
brilliant example of using the reader's
biases against them number six the game
what remains of eda finch number seven
the game the telus principle which is
about ai and sentience and intelligence
and humanity number nine played around
2049 that should be obvious number 10
probably like a rival or stories of your
life which is the short story that
arrival is based on by tich yang both
brilliant and all in their own right
question five for a starting writer what
do you consider the most essential skill
really hard because you know there are
so many skills and they don't really
work independently they all work
together but i guess uh it would have to
be grammar you know understanding the
language that you're actually trying to
use people sort of think of grammar as
like oh it's just the rules of the
language you know the rules of writing
and so they're not very interesting
you've got to remember that grammar
is used for effect like it's used to
create emotions and create experiences
and flow uh in the writing itself it is
as much a tool as the words that you use
and so having a great understanding of
it
is really important you know poetry
uses grammar in some incredible ways for
incredible effect and like
the house of leaves does it all the time
number six how do i find motivation to
get back into writing and deal with
writer's block number one forgive
yourself for not finishing that project
that you said that you would finish
years ago and haven't it's fine i know
that we get attached to like finishing a
particular idea or whatever but really
sometimes it is just better to move on
and that's okay you're not worse for not
having completed it secondly read i know
this is cliche but there is genuinely
nothing more inspiring than reading
great books and going wow i wish i could
write that i wish i could do that and
then doing it i have been able to write
so much more since reading so much more
over the last few years as for writer's
block i often find for me personally
that writer's block is a result of the
story not being where it needs to be so
i look at what i've just written or the
last chapter and i go oh has this been a
misstep should the story have gone in a
different direction and i've sort of
run myself into a wall because suddenly
i find that i can't take the story in a
direction that feels natural and that's
because i didn't set the path leading up
to it
so read back on what you've just written
and ask if there is a way that you can
rewrite that to go in a different
direction seven would you like to
feature more of your own work on the
channel in the future yes i have been
writing short stories all year and i do
want to share more of my fiction book
which i've been trying to do you can see
it in the character descriptions video
and in the recent killing characters
video which people seem to respond
really positively to i also will be
doing like a full reading of the first
chapter of my novel and hopefully a
fully produced version of one of my
short stories called two robots at the
end of the world number eight what is
your fiction book about and how has
writing slash preparing to write your
novel about mental illness impacted your
life in terms of how you deal and view
mental illness this is an interesting
question because it's a little bit back
to front
i use fiction and writing as a way to
process the stuff that i'm going through
so when i started writing this book in
2016 i guess that was the first draft it
was really coming out of a lot of stuff
that i was dealing with
so in a way
the book has been really cathartic it's
been me reflecting on my own personal
experiences how i dealt with things and
i also have learned things you know i
had someone read a book and they said
hey i feel like you could improve the
agency of this character who is mentally
ill by doing this and i was like yeah
that totally works that's good that's
what i want to accomplish uh
it's been giving me more holistic view
of mental health question 9 how do you
decide which examples to highlight in
your world building and writing videos
this is a balance between two things the
popular example the harry potters and
lord of the rings and star wars and game
of thrones and the best example
which is probably from a book that you
haven't read or a film you haven't seen
i try to get a mix of the both of them
because i want people to engage with the
video but i also want to try and explore
it as best i can and there are great
examples in those popular um stories but
they're not necessarily as nuanced as uh
as the other examples could be but i
also think it's a lot harder people to
understand examples that they haven't
seen or read you know i think there's
something really to be appreciated in
using popular examples that are really
accessible you know i think a lot of
writing books for example just spend way
too much time on classic novels and and
obscure stories that no one's read they
feel so inaccessible so unrelatable
question 10 is there a book show or
story in general that you haven't been
able to use as an example in one of your
videos but is nevertheless really good
oh man like i don't know what would fit
this more than house of leaves this book
is insane and i'll just give you give
you an example
it's open
to
look there's like
it that's the formatting that's what
this book looks like
see just blank pages random words
it's a beautiful story full of bizarre
incredible writing and themes and
discussions
but i mean what do i mean to use it as
an example for it's basically a genre of
on its own
um another one would be attack on titan
because
the i mean the story is great i really
really love it but it's complicated uh
it's complicated you know as to what i
should be using in the center before
because i don't think it's like a great
example for exposition delivery or
anything like that or pace maybe the
film about time question 11. you talk at
length about things that you clearly
like almost all of that talk is positive
are there any major things that you
dislike about your favorite series lord
of the rings hatred and dragon avatar
that you leave out or you overlook
because you love them as a whole so this
question is right in that i do have a
general philosophy to focus on the
positive things in a story because i
just think there's enough negativity out
there online but what i will say is that
avatar the last airbender's ending
really could have been tighter you know
people say oh the lion turtles weren't
deus ex machina because we heard about
them before and that's not how dysex
machina works
we would need to have their powers
introduced the powers that they use in
the finale uh for it to be
um
set up prior that's the part that needs
to be set up and also they could have
done a lot better job like making it
clearer how it worked and why it worked
even though it's a phenomenal ending
on the whole
i think that that there are definitely
weaker parts to it that could have
either been changed or at least been
made clearer what they were trying to do
with lord of the rings i can definitely
recognize why it's not for everyone you
know it's not the fastest paced book
and some of the changes that they made
in the films i actually agree with like
i think they make it a better story
giving aragorn a character you could you
can look at lord of the rings and go hey
some of these characters are pretty
one-dimensional i don't think that makes
it a one-dimensional story because i
think tolkien does a lot of really
beautiful
in-depth writing about ideas that he
uses these characters to explore but
saying that some characters in lord of
the rings are one-dimensional isn't an
unfounded criticism christian 12. oh
this is a special one
i was wondering what your thoughts are
on brandon sanderson's the way of kings
and his other work in general alright so
this is gonna come
as a little bit of a shock
but i'm actually not that big a fan of
brandon sanderson
i don't dislike his books i think he's
actually a great guy but his books are
stylistically just not that great in my
view let me put it a different way i've
read mistborn in a way of kings and
skyward and they were good
but i prefer soft magic and i like
writing that is more thematic and poetic
weirdly my favorite book of his is
probably skyward the ending of a way of
kings just blew my mind it really did it
was brilliant but it took way too long
to get there randy sanderson also tends
to write really big scope stories and
for a lot of people they love that but i
tend to prefer more intimate narrow
scope stories at the moment simpson has
undoubtedly changed the genre and he is
a great writer but stylistically it's
just not as much my thing please do not
kill me i feel like i've been like lying
to you because everyone thinks that i am
just the biggest brandon sanderson fan
i'm sorry if you feel betrayed by me
telling you this i am sorry i didn't
mean to mislead you question 13 what
brings you the most uncomplicated joy in
life my cat momo
and maybe milkshakes question 14 explain
what your book is about and the genre
you are writing in
i realize i've been secretive about this
all i'll say is that it's a book about
mental health dealing with it and you
could call it my response to a lot of
the bad mental health books that i have
read as for genre it is
my secret
you thought you were going to get it out
of me didn't you question 15 what are
your major goals this year number one
get my fiction book in the hands of
agents and publishers number two get on
writing world building volume two out
including the audio book before the end
of this year number three get my short
stories published in a magazine bam boom
done question 16 is there any bad
writing advice that people seem to give
each other
so most of the bad advice that i see
people passing around tends to come in
like one of three varieties number one
it's too broad to be helpful you know
you want to write the first chapter and
so they go hey you should introduce your
character and you're like
i know how do i do that and they go
introduce your character number two it's
too narrow to be applicable but number
three there's a lot of people who say
never do this never do that and there
are so many exceptions to every rule you
could possibly imagine that treating
them as rules is just totally unhelpful
it's much easier to say hey these things
worked for some people
here's how they might work for you you
know some of the most interesting
writing that people have ever produced
has been stuff that flaunts the
structures and rules that we think we
have question 17 what story in either
books movies or games frustrated you the
most because it failed to live up to its
potential i only have one answer and
that is valerian and the city of a
thousand planets which has an amazing
world building concept behind it and the
trailers looked great and the film was
terrible and uninteresting it just had a
very mediocre plot and
characters looked way too much like
brother and sister to be dating it is
weirdly a film that was so terrible but
i still want to see a sequel of it where
they do something more interesting
question 18 as youtube's favorite kiwi
what would you say is your favorite
lesser known feature of new zealand we
all know about hobbit and skipping
covert but what's something you love
about new zealand which we may not know
about
i mean have we skipped covert i'm
literally sitting here right now as we
just got put into like a 10-day lockdown
because we found a bunch of covert cases
in auckland
damn aucklanders i think the thing that
most people don't really think about is
low population density so you go
anywhere else in the world america
europe whatever and you go to all these
beautiful places and they're going to be
packed with people hiking tracks are
always going to have tons of people
going up and down them all the time in
new zealand there's so few people here
and so much land and so many beautiful
places that if you go there chances are
you're going to be alone and there's
something really profound and
experiential about being alone in a
beautiful place in nature
that i'm not sure you can get as much in
other places it takes very little to
find yourself alone in nature in new
zealand also because of low population
density we tend to have pretty big
houses compared to other countries which
is something that i would only notice if
i moved somewhere else question 19 how
do you feel knowing you've had such a
positive impact on the writing of so
many also why did you decide to start
writing advice videos despite not having
written a book
wow just
just want to cut right deep don't you
just want to just get right in there i'm
trying i am trying i'm sorry see how i
saw it when i started making those
writing videos was like hey here is this
cool thing in these stories i love i
want to show you how i think they work
because i've always loved studying
stories in that way it's just been kind
of a hobby of mine but of course it's
very easy to take that and turn it into
me teaching people and i guess i do lean
into that now it's kind of my role but
for me it's just always been that i love
studying how stories work and sharing
them with you you know it's kind of like
how book and film critics study and
watch films and books uh and say hey
this works and this doesn't as for the
positive impact it's really hard to
quantify i mean obviously it's it's
amazing i mean there is nothing more
validating for me than people saying hey
i've used your writing videos in my
class or saying hey i signed your book
as like a textbook which is just crazy
uh
but it's all numbers in many ways as
well it's very hard to get a grasp on
like the true reach of it all right i am
back and no longer bleeding question 20
will you ever go back to theories all
right this is old channel stuff if you
went back to my old videos like the
first year year and a half maybe two
years i was doing theory videos about
hatred and dragon and avatar and lord of
the rings you know how did iro get to
the spirit world what happened to the
night furies you know when i made my
first writing video i was like wow this
is what i want to do i got this really
distinct feeling of fulfillment that i
didn't really get with the rest of my
content
and i've always kind of wanted to be
making stuff that i feel nobody else can
giving value to the world and to youtube
that
i don't feel other people are doing or
can do as well as me
and those theory videos even though they
were fun
to make other people can do that sort of
thing and other people are making that
sort of thing but that era of my channel
has largely passed and i mean those
theory channels you know they get to the
point where the theories that they're
making are just wild and conspiratorial
they're really scraping the bottom
barrel and i didn't really want to get
to that point question 21 what are
subfuries
oh god
ah
i am both filled with joy
and horrified that someone is asking
this question
because if you know what they are
you've been here a long time and if you
don't know
i don't really want to tell you so brief
history of the channel i was at
university i made videos that were just
random nonsense for like six months no
one watched them i thought okay i'll
move on i gave it a shot but in the last
few weeks of that i decided to try
different types of videos you know one
literature analysis and one how to train
your dragon theory video six months
later after i sort of quit youtube it
blew up 200 000 views in like a week out
of nowhere and i was like oh my gosh i
have to capitalize on this so i started
making how to train your dragon videos
and for the first like six months of my
channel that was what i made and you
know how it is everyone wants a name for
like what they call the people in their
audience and someone sent me an email
saying hey i'm your sub fury a
subscriber night fury night fury being
the most popular dragon in the how to
train dragon franchise and i was like
wow that's great subscriber fury you
know note that's really cool they're
like dragons and to anyone in the how to
train a dragon audience they know what
it means but then i started adding an
avatar and lord of the ranks and writing
and i had this name and none of them
knew what it meant until one of them
realized it sounds like i'm calling them
my submissive furries
oh
that was a day that was a day the day
that i knew i needed to abandon that
name so i started transitioning away
from it but of course i've got this huge
backlog of videos where i
introduce all of my videos saying hey
subfuries
oh i i cringe um does not mean you're a
submissive furry
i mean unless you are in which case
moving on question 22 i really liked the
whole wang fire teaches a classroom
framing of your video on the anime
genocide what inspired you to use this
framing and will you use it again i was
inspired by how germany teaches about
the holocaust you know we must remember
the past in order to not repeat it but
also i was trying to find a way to talk
about avatar and its law in a way that
nobody else was really doing i wanted to
have a unique way of representing it uh
again because i wanted to create content
that i felt like only i could i do
really want to use it again i don't know
when but it will happen question 23
what's the project you got closest to
finishing but didn't and why
a video on the magical realism genre i
love magical real stories it's where
magic is treated as totally mundane you
know a guy
loses his child and he wakes up with a
hole in his chest and the story isn't
about like oh how is he surviving with a
hole in his chest or how did it come
from or how do we fix it you know it's
focused on the grief and loss of losing
a child with the magic just used as a
mundane way to explore that and i wanted
to make this video about like why
magical realism is so great but i
realized that it was just me saying that
i liked it and i wished other people
would read it more so it wasn't really
me saying anything and i had to scrap it
after a while realizing it wasn't
working question 24 why did you study
philosophy and was it worth it it was
always an interest of mine remember i
had like a an english degree at the same
time and a law degree so the philosophy
stuff was kind of like the fun thing for
me to do it was just out of curiosity i
wanted to look at like the logic behind
the logic behind the ideologies that we
see working in our world to kind of help
me think more critically in a way it
could have delved deeper if i was
perfectly honest but it was a lot of fun
and i really enjoyed it which video
games in your opinion excel in
storytelling but don't have a large
following or a game that you love but
others don't care for
what remains of edith finch probably has
the best story in a game that i have
ever played it's not unpopular but it's
not like super popular because it's part
of a genre that a lot of people don't
play
lesser known would perhaps be the telos
principle it's got a really subtle story
that i think is done really well
uh
as an example of how the gaming like
medium can be used to tell a story 26.
what is momo's favorite pastime activity
aside from plotting the domination of
the milky way galaxy for his
interstellar empire
so
you might not know this but momo can't
jump she can't jump fences or anything
like that which means that she she does
she just kind of sleeps question 27 what
is your favorite trope conspiracy
stories i love it when there's a group
inside the government planning something
and it's like you don't know who to
trust and the people in power are
already corrupt and it's just you on the
run from the law question 28 in your
opinion which villain historical or
fictional has the most interesting story
and character development exempting ones
you've already done essays on
maybe
napoleon he's got a really interesting
story that takes so many twists and
turns
uh especially considering he goes
basically from kind of like a hero-ish
character to very much a tyrant and a
villain fictional i'd be inclined to say
wednesday from neil gaiman's american
gods a brilliant character who is kind
of a villain in the end question 30 will
you read one piece
oh my gosh ever since murph and daniel
started making one piece videos like
this question has been showing up in my
comments
so much more
curse you
the thing is i don't really like stories
that don't have a definitive end i also
just don't really like pirate stories
like the aesthetic and the setting it's
just not that interesting to me i've
never really cared for pirates that much
so i'm sorry but i probably won't and
murph and dan if you're watching this
i'm very sorry i know you're
disappointed in me question 31 what is
your writing routine like now this
question is always hard because i want
to be clear that i am privileged in the
way that i can write you know most
people have a job or school and then
they have to write in their spare time
i'm fortunate enough that i can take
time in my job to write that's a really
different thing but i do tend to take
like a bulk of time and go it from start
to finish i find it very difficult to
move on to another task before i've
finished one i tend to hyper fixate and
with my long affection i have had long
breaks in between the drafts that i've
written just because i need to take the
time to sort of reflect and process it
so the first draft of my book was in
2016 second draft was like 2019 or 2018
and then third draft was in 2020 like
that's how long in between i did with
like my big fiction pieces question 32
what part of writing do you struggle
most with
probably fast-paced stuff i really enjoy
and i'm pretty good at writing
introspective slow moments between
characters i'm not very good at writing
high paced tense moments you know fight
scenes that sort of thing
uh like even my climaxes tend to you
know they rise in tension very sharply
but then they quickly peter off or
something like that i like slow burn
tension which is a lot more low key
both in what i write and read i guess
question 33 you have a lot of content
about western writing but have you ever
read translated asian stories i have
read a couple the biggest series i've
read is the three body problem trilogy
by seashell new the dark forest and
death scene as well and they're really
good but my primary exposure to asian
writing has been through short stories
this year i've read a lot of them
including ones from thai writers
japanese writers chinese writers korean
writers which have been really great
question 34 if you could redo one of
your videos for any reason add more
detail change up the editing or you
don't agree with your original
conclusion which one would it be and why
oh man never ask a content creator this
question because we hate
all of our videos
i have a playlist called watch my best
videos and there's like a series of them
on there and you can comfortably say
that if a video isn't on there then i
have significant problems with whatever
that video is
probably like the self magic systems are
better in here's why video i rushed that
video out because i needed to get some
promotion for the 24 hour charity live
stream uh which means that the argument
i made was a bit compromised and it just
wasn't done very well
or the video on how ira got into the
spirit world i was really pressed for
time for that video and i threw that
theory together and it is not a good
theory it is a terrible
terrible theory that does not make sense
in the slightest if you if you prod it
for more than a second and the dumb
thing was that literally a week later i
came up with a better theory that fit it
even more and i hate it because
obviously the video did so well ah
what you'll find is you'll find that
creators often hate the videos that do
really well because it's not the videos
they want to do well and it makes you
resent them more you know you look at my
most popular videos and all all i think
i don't think oh i love how well my
content's done what i think is why these
videos why not any of the other ones
question 35 what are your criticisms of
philip pullman's his dar material series
so that's the northern lights uh the
subtle knife and the amber spyglass or
the golden compass you're american
basically the first book is a brilliant
critique of religion with a tight
narrative great characters well written
the second book is distracted and
removed from the first that makes it
really hard to get into and doesn't land
the way i think he wanted it to and the
third is just utterly incoherent it
tries to throw every criticism it can
make at the wall and just saw
what would stick he was trying too hard
to say too many things and it didn't
land question 37 have you watched any
good anime or read any manga that you
haven't already talked about i haven't
really discussed death note or attack on
titan very much both of which i really
enjoyed
like attack on titan i'm quite a big fan
of but it's really hard to fit into the
discussions that i'm making because it's
not actually a particularly good example
of many of the things i talk about it's
like something that succeeds in spite of
what it does question 39 what is your
favorite writing or worldbuilding video
oh for writing it would definitely be
character descriptions or fight scenes
which are both recent and i felt like i
just found a real style for them for
we're building maybe the two videos on
we're building the fire nation and the
earth kingdom they were just a lot of
fun and i feel like they hold up after
all this time question 40 what is your
opinion about the 2005 disney film sky
high
it's a beautiful story about
why the lower classes should be happy
with what they've got
question 41 what is the best bread so if
you didn't know i'm a bread goblin i
love all types of bread and i eat way
too much of it and the correct answer to
this is ciabatta question 42 favorite
music genre i like trashy indie music
you know the stuff that all sounds the
same don't at me i like stuff that just
drains into the background uh my
favorite band though is not trashy any
music it is churches
um and you can look up look at this
songs death stranding and graffiti those
are two of my favorite songs question 43
what is your favorite color periwinkle
or royal purple hence why the lighting
in half my videos recently has just been
purple lighting because i just like it
it just looks nice and feels nice
question 44 what is your favorite
shakespeare play
king lear question 45 for the 250th time
are you going to get the avatar game if
you didn't know there is an avatar board
game role-playing game on
kickstarter and i emailed them and said
hey can you send me review coffee you
know because i'm an avatar person using
my clout to get free stuff i feel i feel
guilty and they were like yeah hey we'll
send one out when the kickstarter is
done so i'm gonna get one and i will
review it on the channel i promise you
because if you're in the ttrpg community
and the avatar community this is like a
good
mix and i am in both of those so i'm
excited and i'm also worried that it's
gonna be bad thank you this has been a
lot of fun even though i played in the
middle of it momo instructs you to say
all hail momo down in the comments
better get on to the next video stay
nerdy and i'll see you in the future